Keep your head full and
this one knows
Tan
everyone banaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
Yes, this must be that kind of game.
There's a language for that, and
that's
your ability.
What you're doing is a monotonous attack
I thought you would definitely grab the magic sword Tan
's ability is light as a feather to support the weight of punishment in this era It's heavy
enough that no amount of strength can hold
it
I'm sorry, but you weren't manipulating the right to remember, but you were
manipulating the weight of the
prefecture.